i'm sorry baby i got angry with you
earlier i mean i i i just got really
defensive and um
i don't know what it is i just get so
defensive i get into a rage
in my mind
and it's it used to turn into violence
when i was younger like my brother has
it yeah
but now it just i internalize it and it
just builds in my head and i just start
i can't i don't can't think
why do you let it build it just does
someone will say something or do
something
and it'll just put me into a and only a
couple of people can do it
steve
kalila
my parents
you hold the key
kalyla can do it
i can cut deep she can cut deep well she
knows also sometimes you really deserve
it no i don't
babe i don't humble see that's the
problem between you and i is that you
don't think you're ever wrong i am wrong
all the time no no no you say you're
wrong when there's an audience and then
when it's just you and i oh you take
back all apologies everyone's listening
right now
everyone listen
bobby in a nutshell for you here are my
character flaws here's this i'm faulted
you know i'm a faulty man but but when
it's just him and i he's never wrong
and he will harbor all of this
resentment even though he's wrong
that's why i love this podcast it's the
only time i hear these things from him
where he's like yeah sorry babe you know
i hear real apologies on here and
they're not even real because as soon as
the mics are off look he's already
starting again and you're putting back
back in the room
right now i gotta i gotta speak my truth
babe i cannot these people can have to
know this about you
uh-huh
so the people need to know that because
you're so lovable and funny and all
these things on a mic and i just kind of
wish they saw just a little bit of the
other side of you
you know it runs in the family though
wait what the the dog cause remember dad
yeah well my dad used to um remember he
had a store on riverside he had a van
yeah he would take shits and like paper
on paper plates yeah
you don't remember that oh yeah on a
paper
paper he didn't even want to go to he
was he had to get there
so he would just pull to the side and go
in the back yeah but that's not a you
think that that's a behavioral like am i
believing i don't know have you done
something like this it's in our jeans or
to do that
to maybe poo
public maybe you guys find a thrill out
of it no i had to go
like my dad
i went to a store in phoenix he had a
clothing store yeah and underneath the
cash register you don't even know what i
saw no i don't even know the story
i saw a gigantic jug of
i thought it was water oh this it's all
pee
he pissed in a [ __ ] no what he did
because he couldn't afford any employees
so he would so he couldn't he had to go
to the bathroom and take break he would
pee right there in the jug oh my god
that's hardcore that's commitment
that's good work ethic you used to do
that too yes no he had a truck
no he had a this is back when he had the
white truck the toyota
club
okay so bob had a white truck in san
diego toyota yeah and he would have
frappuccino bottles
come on dude this is real [ __ ]
and it was filled with frappuccino
bottles it with urine in the frappuccino
bottles just stacked there's not even
caps on those that's dangerous no no
i don't remember that
so it doesn't exist yeah i don't
remember it
oh man i remember it are you lying
no
i remember you seeing him he's a pee
collector yes you really i did it on the
balcony here you did i used to pee in
the gigantic green thing okay for years
i i've done it too
tell me about that
mine's gatorade bottles but why the same
yeah same but you collect them on
purpose no no this is the thing
sometimes because i don't want to walk
all the way to the
when i'm in about to go to sleep and i'm
like i'm dozing off
and i have i don't want to walk get up
and walk there
how big is your place how many steps
would you say it takes to walk to your
bathroom i sort of got a four-step
pry from here
to the bathroom out there so
approximately eight steps eight steps
so you'd rather pee i just stand up pee
in the gatorade bottle close it and then
lay back down
so that's how lazy you are that's pretty
lazy yeah it's pretty lazy i'm the same
way i don't know what it is same way you
are i'd rather do that than walk is
i want to start wars
verbally
no listen i'm not gonna we're gonna edit
that other part out we did all right i'm
just saying i'm not gonna name any names
okay
but i'm just gonna say
about my personality i'm gonna just
share a little glimpse of
what i do that's not a good thing
okay is what i'm doing it's unhealthy
it's unhealthy is it that
i have little mini
um resentments
and i things that i feel about certain
comedians actors whoever
and i want to jab at them
i want to poke it right is there a
reason behind it yeah because i feel
like i was slighted
you know or socially where something
happened where
i felt like i was hurt by them someone
just belittled you were condescending
right
condescending or something
and in my head i perceive it
in the wrong way
most of the time
you take it like they don't like me
they're mean to me they have something
against me or what they said was you
know
oh yeah that's funny everyone's laughing
at me
okay i'll get you
you know oh so she said something she
did somebody we're going to edit that
but we don't know who so when you're
listening tonight there's a he or she
that slided me we're not gonna we're not
sorry i have those people right and so
then what i do is i'll jab and i've
started little wars with people and they
don't end
and they continue
and there's a couple out there that i
did early on you know on this podcast
where they're still out there and it's
still a little thing and it's weird but
doesn't it keep things spicy it does
isn't it okay not to have be friends
with everybody look
not everybody's gonna like you
in this room right now there's probably
one person i won't make names
but they're thinking he's not that funny
yeah he's not as funny as we hoped he'd
be you're thinking about me no no me i'm
thinking somebody in this room doesn't
think i'm as funny as i probably should
be maybe i'm gonna say this there's no
way okay but somebody in this building
there's no one in this building no all
i'm saying is it's an analogy yeah yeah
yeah i'm saying that you can't you
[ __ ] when you do at the comedy store
there's 600 people
laughing their [ __ ] dick off and that
bobby lee's the funniest [ __ ] guy and
there's probably four or five people
that are like oh i know i can point them
out in the audience
as soon as driving
i made it in they get up to go to the
bathroom
right yeah and i go oh there's jackass
going to the bathroom because he doesn't
like my comments do you ever mention it
are you learning i'll say i'll say it
you're allowed you do that yeah yeah oh
where are you going buddy yeah i i do
that you don't want gays
i say minorities or i go um oh yeah you
don't like um guys that are dynamic
you are dynamic
my point is is that there is that and um
but it is this character defect i don't
think that's a good thing
i don't think it is you want everybody
to like you it's not that i there are
still there are peop there's
a couple of comics that i've said things
about
that have this little war with me that i
um
when i see them i have to avoid them and
they have to avoid me it's a conscious
thing
and i've always been like that i've
always had these little tiny little
things you like being in that well i
know i'm just saying that i think that
it's a character defect i think that it
is a trait within myself that i jab i
jab and you don't want to get rid of it
you like that i know i'm saying i meant
and i have this thing inside me that
they compare i compare myself to other
people
and i go
you're a loser
you didn't do this you didn't do that
look what everyone else is doing
he specifically is one case that i've
never felt
like that for because he's always been
good to me
we've always been friends like real
friends and we've always and we've had
fights and stuff but just like squabbles
or whatever but
i've always loved him i've always loved
his brother and his parents i love josh
myers too he was another one that was
with ike back then and mad yeah so that
was like your score appeal just you
three was yours no i can't peel okay i
mean they were you know
a squad you know and um
in fact anyone from my generation of mad
tv
i have
just such love for and support like
key and peel killed it they're my
generation and i you know you know
there's there there is a thing where you
look at
you know entertainment weekly or the
front page of the new york times to see
these two guys on it there is a feeling
of pride
and like wow
it's heavy
to be on the cover of esquire yeah and
two guys you know that
i was on a sketch show with and um
i just have love there are other people
that i don't feel that way about i get
really jealous and angry and resentful
i'm not gonna name names
you know i'm not gonna name names but um
we can all assume we can always sit and
make assumptions yeah you know but
i don't you know what you know what's so
funny is is
howard mendel
you know him yeah you know howie mandel
dealer no deal deal
yeah but um
he said something to me the other day
that really [ __ ] cleared it up
it was like a nugget of knowledge
that i wish i had five years ago
he was saying he was at the comedy store
and he was like he was going up and i go
wow you've been going up a lot lately
and he goes yeah because i'm doing
montreal
and i go
oh i was offered to do in montreal this
year
but i didn't take it because
i still have resentments
because when i was a younger comic they
never brought me into new faces or you
know you never did it and i never did it
if you guys don't know montreal is a
comedy um festival
yeah huge comedy fans of all you blow up
and people get deals out of there and
it's a huge thing for comics to go and i
wasn't i wasn't invited for 15 years
in comedy
it's only recently where i've been
getting invites but i've said no to them
because of this resentment and how he
was mad he looked at me and goes you
never make decisions based on emotion
and i go what do you mean he goes if i
if i would if i made decisions based on
emotion i would have never taken deal or
no deal which
is the thing that reinvented my career i
really did right because he didn't want
to do it at first but his wife said you
have to do it
right and he goes you know what i'm
gonna get over my petty whatever and i'm
gonna not make a decision based on my
emotions and just do it because it's
work and it reinvented him and i from
now on for the rest of my life i will do
that
you know i'm gonna push aside resentment
and all that [ __ ] that's oh it's
only in my head it is mostly in your
head and your suffering is in our head
especially with someone like you i mean
even something as simple as dinner
tonight where i didn't go say hi to
danny
you and your you sat in front of me and
you said
that's it he'll never work with me again
did you really he'll never work with me
again you ruined it my relationship with
him is over what if he becomes this big
big time director and he'll never it's
like it ever i mean it's not like i just
say those things yes he did
i didn't say those things but that's how
his brain operates
i know what she's saying i didn't say
those things out loud but she no i
didn't say all those things out loud
right but i i understand what she's
saying this is that
she's making a point it's zero to one
hundred it's zero to one hundred
i make assumptions about things yeah you
know like
i'll go into an audition and i think in
my head
that i was terrible
right
and then for a month i'll be like i'm
never gonna make it work again on all
that stuff
and then a month later you get a call
you got it
what that job
that you auditioned to a month ago
and all that torturing i did for a month
in my head
was
for nothing i can't believe you let that
consume you it's an energy what that
really consumes you small little things
consume him
like we went to a wrap party a few years
ago
and someone was he had he had ran into
somebody he knew a big time actor
it that he knows very well he's friends
with but they were passing each other in
the elevator so there's not much time to
really chit-chat right because elevator
is dinging there's other people waiting
and so he the guy was kind of like oh
hey bobby but then bye bobby and then
bought on the whole ride home he was
like he hates me
our relationship is over
did i make myself look weird like all
these questions no it's a character
defect i just admitted to it i already
know it it's crazy it's crazy mental
insanity building stories in your head i
build these false things in my head
and then it's like i
it's all it's nonsense
it's all just my brain just as a defense
mechanism creates these fantasies
and then i actually start to believe
them and i want to stop doing it yeah i
get that when you expose
your embarrassing you know your your
character defects or things that you've
done that are embarrassing or i'll never
tell anybody you know
that
i've told everyone everything
i don't know if that's healthy or not i
think it's good i've noticed that about
you and i love that about you like i
like the uh down syndrome guy molesting
you yeah it's just
to be able to just say that and move on
i think
is lib i can see liberating to you and i
think it makes people respect you too in
a way this is like oh [ __ ] like how do
you come to terms with something that
dark that casually you know yeah it's
interesting and it's admirable but i did
it out of survival
you know i did it out of um
just to keep my career going it's weird
it what happened was after i was on mad
tv
i've talked about this before many times
but i'll do it again um
it's okay people want to listen to it i
um
i couldn't work
and nobody wanted me in the town you
know you know why is that
i think um
you know mad tv had a weird
reputation around town at the time
it did it there wasn't it no one became
a star after that show at that time
right and um it was just seen as ghetto
and
casting directors would be like nah i'm
not gonna see him he was on mad tv and
what not and they would say that i mean
to my reps and they i would get the
information and um
i was like i don't know how i'm gonna
and i was at open anthony in new york
and this is when get greg geraldo and um
patrice o'neill were still alive right
and i went on that show and they ripped
me
to pieces about what just about how fat
i am and they just came in they're like
yeah
yeah they were just ripping me apart
to the point they were doing pranks on
me and it got to the point where i got
up
from the show
and i [ __ ] laugh that's so [ __ ] up
wow like almost crying wow and i'm like
i'm never going to do that again you
know
and then the next year
i'm back in new york and i look at my
press pack
and it says i have to still have to do
opening again and they're like i go i
don't want to do them and they're like
you have to that's the only real big one
you have
but this time
when i went on the show i exposed
everything up front
and it took the power away from them
you know it's like um
they couldn't use anything against me
because i had already like thrown it out
there
so i threw out i was yeah it sucked
dicks before that i
that was all from that one interview
yeah damn i saw dicks i was molested
just went up come on yeah i just went
blazing what's up now yeah and then they
were like oh he's out of material then
he gets she gets his girlfriend's
information
and he throws everyone under the bus so
he's not just talking about his deepest
darkest he takes our deepest darkest and
he throws it all out there
it's a bad thing it's a character defect
and i i i
did you feel powerful in that meeting
did you flip the tables or was there
did it work for you not only did it work
but it became i became friends and um
but you know i came home and i um needed
to catch up
on the destiny
because everyone did
i played the whole time i was gone
and now i'm behind
and i played yesterday but i got in
trouble
why did he get in trouble kalyla
um let's see he comes through the door
drops his suitcase gets a hog and doss
[Laughter]
turns our home into an absolute just
like crime scene yeah that watches the
dog you know piss in front of him on the
floor
and then proceeds to scream for 10 hours
straight at the tv i mean tell me
what what type of person i would have to
be
to not at least be to be even you know
annoyed
and
i didn't
that i was trying to communicate to him
and then he goes oh hey i'm going to
dinner with eric at 7 30. mind you i've
been sick all weekend didn't offer me no
food okay
no meds then offer me a kiss or a hug
shut the [ __ ] up with your own man oh
you didn't kiss you look at me right now
wait wait wait stop right now right now
no it's not right here babe i'm sorry i
apologize but i wanna look at me right
now if you ever give me a [ __ ] o like
that again my friend all right you you
have another thing coming which is i
don't know
oh god it's a mystery it's a mystery
it's a mystery one all right so i want
you to [ __ ] apologize gilbert i'm
sorry that i said oh when you didn't
kiss your girlfriend when you got home
you're welcome
and i forgive you oh go ahead baby
um
i mean it's the same argument we always
have i have a pretty high threshold for
video
she's the best girlfriend in the world i
don't tell him when to stop i don't give
him like a treat baby baby but yesterday
i was sick and i just needed a little
bit of like hi kalylah i know you exist
and you're sick and you're dying on a
bed i needed just just an ounce of it
that's it and i was trying to
communicate that to him and all he said
to me was i'm after playing 10 hours he
says i don't want to talk about it i'm
too tired i need a nap
and then he goes and
doesn't talk to me okay and then naps
yeah yeah and um and then um
he wakes up he goes to dinner and then
at dinner he realizes what no he had
done it stop stop stop stop stop stop
okay number one okay i want you to
apologize
what for what
i want you to apologize right now
kalylah
for what just to do it just
he always makes me do this yeah just to
do it you say i am so sorry you know
what bobby i really am sorry that you
have just zero
capacity
i heard sorry and there's a sense of
pride
there's a sense of like it's almost
mind-boggling
yeah because you kind of go
wow yeah right
and then
there's it and i i was telling will this
in the hallway
they're always there's and this is a
character defect of mine there's always
a sense of
what the [ __ ] have i been doing geez
dude you're mean like it always goes
back to my [ __ ] stupid narcissistic
ego [ __ ] driven yeah you know
personality of like what the [ __ ]
you've been playing [ __ ] scar stardew
valley
16 hours a day got fish what what you
got good fish i don't have to get good i
have to finish it but um he pissed off
his wife in the video game and now she's
not talking to him
no well what happened was and he i had
to hear it for a full hour today no no
what happened no it would have there's
no consequences what happened hayley of
pink cake and haley i'm trying to offer
my relationships with she maybe she
has it's a farming simulation game
called stardew valley and i've been
playing it for 16 hours a day oh okay
yeah you won an academy award someday
don't be hard on yourself
just like whatever right yeah right i i
was i said this to you in the hallway i
thought it was very interesting how
jordan said i stopped and started
writing this screenplay 20 times i
walked away from it 20 times going no
one's gonna yeah blah blah and you have
that same cross to bear you got to get
that wife in the farm game
to start talking to you again it doesn't
matter if it takes 20 times
we all have goals right yeah jordan you
know you don't just rub it in my face
dude i have addictions oh yeah all right
i have [ __ ] addictions you know what
i went on twitter yeah and i saw a
lovely picture or it was on instagram of
keegan giving jordan a really big hug he
was so happy for him and the meme was
what the kids were saying was give me
one friend of my life
like keegan michael key
you know like jordan has in keegan
michael keaton yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah and if and if the key in key
and peel
is happy for peel i'm [ __ ] happy i'm
[ __ ] are you really
are you ready
i've ever said today hey should we start
the show over
no i think let's just start this this is
how i always do it yeah yeah this is
amazing
i know yeah i like mixing oh big things
yeah yeah
and i like it when it's like kind of
like advised just disheveled shoveled
like all over the place on your podcast
you have a structure you do and a
producer
i have a producer too this phone guy has
a pink dick
that uh nullifies old yeah yeah no but
you know i like it but it's not a little
chaotic you know i love it this show has
been so much fun i know but can i just
say this so how come i haven't been on
yours i've asked you i've been
[ __ ] you have never asked me and
that's you know what i'm gonna say this
i swear to god bobby can i tell you what
you said
i swear to god i can't tell you what you
suffer from pull up your text messages
i'm sure there's proof of that yeah no
because this is a new phone so
exactly
you always change your number why no no
no no no let me tell you something yeah
can i tell you something i'm pretty sure
your lady is going to agree with me you
ready yes
bobby will lie and believe his lie yeah
believe it to the to the to the point
where he'll cry
like tears and sell it to you we've
talked about it on here he is a great
great liar liar yeah
great liar and he believes his life so
much so that is real now it's a truth
now it's real to him yeah
it's like oj it's like oj it's not like
okay it's like okay
oj oj honestly thinks he didn't murder
the entire house i don't like oj it is
like oh geez never kill the white [ __ ]
or the guy that waiter a waiter but i
guarantee if you did i would lie about i
would lie about it and you would get
away with it yeah don't incriminate
yourself yeah man so when i tell people
i was at pearl harbor they people i
believe that you believe you were at
pearl harbor because renaissance did the
911 thing
so i've been doing pearl harbor
and people don't very very topical yeah
yeah yeah
jump right down
you were there i was there man i was
sleeping in the bunker
pearl harbor hawaii 1944
1940 i go yeah
and i heard the kamikaze is it coming
down man
and then my black friend who looks like
cubie good and jittery had a little
[ __ ] machine gun
he was a chef and he you know
what
but no i have told people that and i
have lied a lot
i lie about things a lot yeah you're
right but you know what you can show him
a text message yeah he'll fight it proof
exhibit a exhibit b exhibit c and he's
like i did not write that yeah
yeah what yes yeah i could be like bobby
why did you text this to this person and
you're like that's not my phone and he
was like that's not he'll come i texted
caps yeah those are lower
is that is that a character diff law
what the way you're speaking yes
no my lines just your teeth missing
i have one tooth missing over here she
said six and anyone knows your mouth
it's her do i you know i have so many
times how many teeth how many teeth he's
got like six missing in the back row
come on let's fix this i can chew fine i
could just choose in the front yeah but
you're a public figure
fine i chew them with my front smile and
look to the right smile look to the
right now you can't see it i don't know
just do it smaller look to the right go
yeah we got to fix that
oh my god
yes yeah i'm sorry
because they were like i'm going to
let's raise money no really i don't even
have the money kickstarter i can [ __ ]
fix it like like every two thousand
dollars we put like a tooth that says 2
000.
because they were they said that they
were gonna have to drill na like uh
like i'm not doing that i should get it
into the skull part upper skull upper
skull upper gum
yeah into the bone yes and then they
screw it in is that a jaw can you just
google it you have a computer yeah well
you can use it upper jungle too man
that's your job yeah but he has a
computer that's on you dick okay god
they call it the uh max uh m-a-x-i-l
that's what i was gonna say maxilla
which is the meat that you serve at your
restaurant
so i do i do and that's the character
defect i'm gonna change that
about myself yeah
yeah you should do that
no no i'll tell you what you know
you're you're making you are who you are
it makes life more yes his
life motto is lie to win yes
lie to win and i've been doing that all
my life i mean i guess you know people
people are missing multiple chips like
thank god we have empathy thank god that
we're sensitive people but a lot of
people
are missing many chips
and that's just the reality of the world
you know and i'm sure we're missing some
chips
i don't think i am
i think i'm going to make all these
several chips
like what chips am i not missing what
ships am i missing the cleaning chip
the washing your own ass chip yeah but
those aren't chips those are like chips
those are pretzels those are pretzels
yeah yeah that's our pretzels yeah you
have chocolates my butt yeah my pothole
the state of my butthole
doesn't affect
the people around me are you sure yeah
i beg to disappoint you you haven't i
ever asked you to eat my butthole i've
done this and it smelled like butthole
yeah but that's like well
yeah i mean that's like um i smell the
chocolate chips that's like living in
turkey and then like smelling what's
going on in syria yeah
it's adjacent
i don't know if that analogy makes sense
but yeah it's adjacent they're adjacent
they're close together you know
so um yeah you don't think you're
missing any chips i really don't and if
you can tell me what chips i'm missing i
can maybe address it to you right now
but i don't think that i have any chips
missing no um are you like i don't
believe i think that nascar that sport
is ridiculous
they're going in a circle
in a car 200 miles per hour 200 miles
per hour i don't give a [ __ ] i don't
know why anyone likes it but they do and
i believe that it's fun for them
and i'm going to give you an example of
that the baseball
i hated it i don't like watching it yeah
right but then i've never seen a game i
mean i would try as a kid or throughout
my life to watch and got this sucks
but that [ __ ] cubs um
was it cleveland cleveland game that was
exciting those were amazing
then you got it you go oh
this is exciting i get why people
you know so
i have a chip to grow i can grow but i
don't have any chips
do you think you're missing gilbert
um
what are the different chips like what
are the main chips i mean just in
general what do you think is missing in
your overall character
in your ability in your just like your
emotional ability
uh i would say to be
very vulnerable to people um
so you you don't some people i talk to
even like you guys but just other people
they're open to talk about their
problems yeah but there are chips that
affect other if you're missing some
chips that affects others that affects
other people i don't think i have those
chips oh i see what you're saying okay
you know it's like
i don't know but i might i do what is
that affects others sometimes i
you know you and i speak so freely and
in this podcast we think this is our
real world that we can talk about you
know like blown off penis parts
but when when i step out to my doctor's
office or i step out into the real world
i can't speak like that but sometimes
i do and it makes people not so
comfortable yeah but see to me
to me
that's them missing a chip
that's not you missing a chip no
no no because let me tell you this right
now that we live in america right and i
can say whatever i want if it doesn't
hurt anyone's feelings and by me talking
about my butthole of what i would do if
my
if i was an explosion and i took a head
and i stuck it on my thing i mean i
believe that that's not you know i mean
that's on you
i can still talk about that if i want to
yeah that's not me missing a chip
sometimes i have a lack of impulse
control chip where i think and i act so
quickly emotionally and then i say
things to people and then i i
you know that hurt them and then i fully
regret it after
yeah i have a lot of character defects
man you don't have a lot just a few
i have many of them but that's still
like
normal a normal amount you know i mean i
don't i just don't think that
but maybe i'm right or i'm wrong maybe i
do have i'm maybe i'm a damaged person
and i have a lot of things that
are missing
and these are things i want to discover
later and grow
that's the point of life you know you're
right because
i find that my favorite people on earth
are damaged i've never
had a pleasant
like encount pleasant but that's it it
stops right there it's pleasant
encounters with people who are just you
know not rule breakers who are very like
in the box did everything right i find
that i don't often have a lot of things
like in common with them or even just to
talk about like they're nice
they're pleasant but that's where it
ends you know
like i like people i like people like
you
just destroyed thanks baby you're
destroyed too oh
you know guys um
this has been a
pretty good podcast i thought it was fun
i thought that um we learned a lot today
and i did it
i learned so much more about you guys
about chips
about um bearing come what